okay but there is another person
um who is of note
um rihanna
she has not come on the podcast
but is it true
that god sat next to her at an event and
what happened please tell me the story
because i might have something for you
and then we might be able to do
something together oh my god at the
moment i'm so red okay years ago when i
was doing one tree hill my character was
becoming a fashion designer so i was
like coming to fashion week here and
meeting with all these people and
learning about how they do what they do
for research
and i went to this dinner
and rihanna comes to this dinner and we
sit next to each other and she's like
your show's cool we're chatting i'm
dying she gives me her phone number
which i input in my blackberry at the
time
and i never texted her and then that
photo you showed i saw her at an event
years later and she was like how have
you been i never heard from you and i
was like oh my god i ghosted rihanna
like what is wrong with me but i just
i'm like what do i what am i gonna text
her like hey girl what
i don't know how to talk to her okay so
i
got to spend time with oprah winfrey in
montecito and
she was like i live around the corner
come over let's make soup no and i just
was way too intimidated to be like hey
like
should we follow through on that like
plan
so what if we
ask rihanna and oprah for a re-do i
would love it
i would like absolutely social scaredy
cat redo we'll just show up and be like
hey ladies the awkward girls are here
totally hi
what's wrong with us and like rihanna's
having a baby and i'm so happy for her
and i'm like i can't even tell her
congratulations because i never texted
her baby clothes
that's the end and i'll get over some
soup and send it to her okay
we're gonna come out of our show
incredible opportunity look at nice time
that both you and i were too nervous to
follow through on out of respect
too much respect yeah i just blank i'm
like how do i open this text message and
then i just don't well one thing you do
know is design i love your design
i'm obsessed with design
i was actually in the offices at el
decor when they were picking out the
cover which was your house no it's so
impressive it's so beautiful
[Applause]
and um
you know high to low you have this
fabulous house and then also um you have
been crafting mushrooms on instagram
yeah
um which i also love and i was wondering
if you would do a crafting segment with
us i would literally love nothing more i
got so obsessed with making a couple of
these cute little red and white
christmas ornaments that i like blacked
out and before i knew it i'd made 67 of
them so i had to get it i had to get
that tiny tree just to put the rest on i
was like what do i do here and funnily
enough
instagram just pulled down my christmas
highlight that was saved on my page
because they said i was promoting the
sale of illegal goods and i was like
these are paper mache they're not
psychedelic
all right when we come back sophia and i
are gonna do some crafts of our own and
our dear friend sarah t and leo kelly
will be joining us we'll be right back
[Music]
you